दो भाई थे अतापी और वतापी दोनों साथ स्कूल
गए कॉलेज गए एक ही जगह नौकरी करी फिर एक
दिन बैठ के दोनों भाइयों ने देखी जिंदगी
ने मिलेगी दोबारा और देख के लगा अरे वाह
क्या लाइफ है भाई साहब हम भी स्पेन जाएंगे
टमाटर से खेलेंगे लेकिन सेविंग तो थई नहीं
जेब में पैसे भी नहीं तो क्या करें उधार
ले लेते हैं उधार के लिए जिन-जिन दोस्तों
को फोन किया सबने फोन ब्लॉक कर दिया क्यों
क्योंकि उधार के बारे में सबको पता है कि
मांगने वाला एक बार मांगता है और देने
वाला बार-बार मांगता है जब कहीं से उधारी
ना मिली तो कहा भैया स्पेन तो जाएंगे
टमाटर बुला रहे हैं तो फिर उन्होंने कर
दिया बैंक में लोन अप्लाई और भाई साहब
अतापी का हो गया लोन पास और वतापी का हो
गया रिजेक्ट और वतापी को खुद का लोन
रिजेक्ट होने से टेंशन तो थी पर उससे बड़ी
टेंशन थी कि अरे अतापी का कैसे सिलेक्ट हो
गया मुझे लोन क्यों नहीं दिया गया ऐसा
क्या खास था अतापी में ऐसी क्या कमी रह गई
मुझ बतापी में मेरे पास गाड़ी भी है बंगला
भी है मां भी है फिर बैंक बोला अतापी का
क्रेडिट स्कोर 750 से ज्यादा है और वतापी
तुम्हारा जो स्कोर है वो 550 है बैंक ने
कहा तुम्हारी जो गाड़ी है ना उसपे भी लोन
है और जो तुम्हारा बंगला है इस पे भी लोन
है ये जो फोन है इस पे भी लोन है तुम्हारे
पास क्रेडिट कार्ड है तीन और वो भी चार
बार डिफॉल्ट कर चुके हो तब जाके वता भी को
पता पड़ा कि क्रेडिट स्कोर नाम की भी कोई
चीज होती है जिसके बेसिस पे बैंक या
एनबीएफसी तय करती है कि किसको लोन देना है
किसको लोन नहीं देना किसको किस रेट पे लोन
देना है क्रेडिट कार्ड देना है कि नहीं
देना और देना है तो क्रेडिट कार्ड में
कितनी लिमिट देनी है किसको कितने ऑफर
मिलेंगे ये सब क्रेडिट स्कोर पे डिपेंड
करता है भाई साहब लेकिन क्रेडिट स्कोर
होता क्या है ये बनता कैसे है आप जो
व्यूअर सुन रहे हैं आपका क्रेडिट स्कोर
क्या है और यह आपको पता कैसे चलेगा अगर
आपका कम है तो कम क्यों है और अगर कम है
तो भैया इसको बढ़ाएंगे कैसे यह ई पे फोन
लेना ई पे गाड़ी लेना ठीक है कि नहीं
क्रेडिट कार्ड एक ही लेना चाहिए या एक से
ज्यादा भी ले सकते हैं क्रेडिट कार्ड की
लिमिट पूरी खर्च करनी है कि आधी खर्च करनी
चाहिए अगर यह सब आप सोच रहे हो तो मत सोचो
कि इन सबके आंसर अगले 5 मिनट में देगा
आपका राहुल आपको भी और वतापी को भी
[संगीत]
सबसे पहले बात करते हैं क्रेडिट स्कोर
होता क्या है सर जी क्रेडिट स्कोर एक ऐसा
स्कोर होता है जो यह बताता है कि भैया
आपका अब तक का फाइनेंशियल लेनदेन कैसा है
आपने कितने लोन ले रखे हैं उनको टाइम से
चुकाया है कि नहीं चुकाया है पूरा चुकाया
कि नहीं चुकाया है इन सबके बेसिस पे आपको
एक स्कोर दिया जाता है उसको कहते हैं
क्रेडिट स्कोर गवर्नमेंट ने इसके लिए कुछ
एजेंसी को लाइसेंस दे रखा है जो ये सारा
डाटा मेंटेन करती है और उसके बेसिस पे
आपको स्कोर देती है ऐसी एक एजेंसी का नाम
है सिबिल तो भाई साहब बहुत सारे लोग
क्रेडिट स्कोर को ही सिविल स्कोर बोलते
हैं बल्कि ऐसा नहीं है सिविल एक कंपनी है
जो क्रेडिट स्कोर प्रोवाइड कराती है ऐसी
और भी कई कंपनीज हैं जिनको सीआईसी क्रेडिट
इंफॉर्मेशन कंपनीज कहते हैं आप सिविल के
अलावा किसी सीआईसी को जानते हो तो कमेंट
बॉक्स में बताओ और अगर आपको ये इंफॉर्मेशन
नहीं लगी हो र है हमको तो पता ही नहीं था
ये एजेंसी है तो भैया वीडियो को लाइक ठोक
देना इसी भी इंफॉर्मेशन पे और अभी ऐसे
दो-तीन फैक्ट और देने वाला हूं तो सर जी
एजेंसी करती क्या है देखो एजेंसी सिंपल सा
काम करती है आपके लिए गए लोन का और उसके
चुकाने का पूरा हिसाब मेंटेन रखती है है
और जब आप किसी नए लोन के लिए क्रेडिट
कार्ड के लिए अप्लाई करते हो तो यह सारी
चीज का डाटा निकाल के बैंक को देती है एक
सीआई आर यानी क्रेडिट इंफॉर्मेशन रिपोर्ट
अब तक का आपका सारा लेखाजोखा एक स्कोर के
साथ और स्कोर पे आधार पे बैंक तय करती है
कि भैया आपकी क्रेडिट वर्दी देस यानी आपकी
उधार चुकाने की क्षमता कैसी है कैसी नहीं
इसमें आपने अब तक कितने लोन लिए कितने
चुकाए कितने डिफॉल्ट किए सब चीजों का
डेटाबेस होता है और उस बेसिस पे आपको
स्कोर मिलता है क्रेडिट स्कोर जो कि 300
से लेक 900 के बीच में होता है 300 से 525
के बीच में है तो भैया यह बिल्कुल अच्छा
स्कोर नहीं है 525 से 600 एवरेज होता है
600 से 700 अच्छा होता है 701 से 750 बहुत
अच्छा होता है और 750 से ऊपर एक्सीलेंट अब
ये स्कोर देख के आपके मन में आ रहा होगा
यार राहुल जी मेरा क्या स्कोर है कोई बात
नहीं अभी देख लेते हैं एक बार स्कोर देख
के पता पड़ जाएगा कहां पे आप स्टैंड करते
हो फिर उसको बढ़ाना कैसे है उस पे बात कर
लेंगे अब वैसे तो क्रेडिट स्कोर देखने के
बहुत सारे ऑप्शन हैं बहुत सारे ऐप हैं
लेकिन अभी आपको मैं बताता हूं सबसे आसान
सबसे बड़ी तरीका अबन चलते हैं सीधे-सीधे
पैसा बाजार पे यह अपन ग भैया पैसा बाजार
की वेबसाइट पे सबसे पहले अपन को ये दिखा
फ्री क्रेडिट रिपोर्ट मोबाइल नंबर डाला
उसने ओटीपी मांगा ओटीपी डाल दिया साहब अब
इस पे क्लिक करते ही आपको इंस्टेंट सारी
रिपोर्ट मिल जाएगी कब-कब कितने-कितने लोन
लिए थे क्या हुआ क्या नहीं हुआ इस पैसा
बाजार पे जाके जो क्लिक है डाउनलोड
रिपोर्ट का इस पर जब आप क्लिक करेंगे दो
ऑप्शन देगा एक तो क्रेडिट हेल्थ रिपोर्ट
और एक यह देगा बेसिक क्रेडिट हेल्थ
रिपोर्ट यहां पे जाके जब आप क्लिक करेंगे
गेट योर रिपोर्ट ये पूछेगा भैया कौन सी
लैंग्वेज में चाहिए यह आपको इंग्लिश हिंदी
मराठी और बाकी मल्टीपल लैंग्वेज में डाटा
प्रोवाइड कराता है इसको आप डाउनलोड कर
सकते हो या आपके कंप्यूटर में लैपटॉप में
मोबाइल में फाइल डाउनलोड हो जाएगी आप इसको
पूरी स्टडी करके देख सकते हो क्या कमी है
क्यों कमी है और इसपे
बार क्रेडिट स्कोर चेक करने से स्कोर कम
हो जाता है क्या ये सही है राहुल जी ये
सही भी है और गलत भी दो टाइप का क्रेडिट
स्कोर चेक होता है एक होता है सॉफ्ट चेक
एक होता है हार्ड चेक सॉफ्ट चेक वो चेक
होता है जो व्यक्ति खुद का स्कोर खुद ही
देखता है यह चेक करने के लिए मैं कहां
खड़ा हूं या उसकी सपोज कोई कंपनी है वो
अपने एंप्लॉई का चेक करवा ले या फिर कोई
कंपनी है उसको बेनिफिट क्या देना है
डिस्काउंट क्या देना है उसके लिए स्कोर
देख ले इसको कहते हैं सॉफ्ट क्रेडिट चेक
इसको बार-बार चेक करने से भी आपके क्रेडिट
स्कोर पे कोई इंपैक्ट नहीं आता जैसे भी
मैं ने आपको चेक करके बताया इससे मेरे
क्रेडिट स्कोर पे बिल्कुल फर्क नहीं
पड़ेगा एक होता है हार्ड क्रेडिट चेक वो
क्या होता है जब भी आप बैंक में लोन के
लिए अप्लाई करते हो क्रेडिट कार्ड के
अप्लाई करते हो और बैंक या भाई साहब कोई
भी एजेंसी एनबीएफसी अपने पोर्टल से अप्लाई
करती है यह देखने के लिए उसको कहते हैं
हार्ड चेक उसमें अगर आपको मान लो लोन मिल
गया तो बात खत्म पर अगर लोन नहीं मिला और
वहां रिजेक्ट हो गया तो भाई साहब आपका
क्रेडिट स्कोर पे इंपैक्ट आएगा तो सर जी
बढ़िया क्रेडिट स्कोर का फायदा क्या है
बहुत सारे फायदे हैं पांच तो अभी गिन लो
पहला लोन की अप्रूवल फटाफट आती है सेकंड
जो रेट मिलती है वो काफी सस्ती मिलती है
जिसका क्रेडिट स्कोर अच्छा होता है उसको
थोड़ा सस्ती रेट पे लोन मिलता है जिसका कम
होता है उसको ज्यादा रेट पे मिलता है
क्रेडिट कार्ड ले रहे हो तो लिमिट अच्छी
मिलती है नॉर्मल व्यक्ति को मान लो 50000
की लिमिट मिल रही है जो अच्छे स्कोर वाले
को 1 लाख की लिमिट भी मिल सकती है ये जो
प्रोसेसिंग चार्ज जो अदर चार्ज है उस पे
भी डिस्काउंट मिलता है अच्छे क्रेडिट
स्कोर वाले को तो सर जी क्रेडिट स्कोर
कैलकुलेट कैसे होता है क्रेडिटेड स्कोर
कैलकुलेट होने के चार क्राइटेरिया है
चारों करके आपको बताता हूं ध्यान से सुनना
इसी से आपका ऊपर या नीचे होता है सबसे
पहला क्राइटेरिया है प्रीपेमेंट हिस्ट्री
भैया आज तक जितने भी लोन लिए हैं टाइम से
चुकाए कि नहीं चुकाए यह बता दो और पूरे
चुकाए कि नहीं चुकाए यह बता दो अगर आपने
जितने ज्यादा लोन लिए और उतने ज्यादा टाइम
से चुका दिए तो भैया क्रेडिट स्कोर अच्छा
होगा और अगर टाइम से नहीं चुका है डिफॉल्ट
कर दिया एक दो कित ऊपर नीचे है तो भैया
स्कोर नीचे चला जाएगा दूसरी चीज जिस पर
क्रेडिट को डिपेंड करता है आपका क्रेडिट
टाइप कैसा है ल जी ये क्या हुआ दो तरह के
लोन होते हैं एक होता है सिक्योर्ड जिसके
अगेंस्ट आपने कुछ रखा होता है जैसे कार
लोन में आपकी कार गिरवी पड़ी है होम लोन
में घर गिरवी पड़ा है या लोन अगेंस्ट
गोल्ड है तो गोल्ड गिरवी पड़ा है ये होता
है सिक्योर्ड लोन और एक होता है
अनसिक्योर्ड लोन जिसके अगेंस्ट आपने कुछ
नहीं दे रखा जैसे मान लो बैंक बिजनेस लोन
ले लिया आपने या पर्सनल लोन ले लिया आपने
या क्रेडिट कार्ड ले लिया इन दोनों में
रेशो देखा जाता है अगर आपने सिक्योर्ड लोन
ज्यादा ले रखा है अनसिक्योर्ड कम है तो
क्रेडिट स्कोर अच्छा आएगा पर आपने
सिक्योर्ड लोन तो कम है और अनसिक्योर्ड
ज्यादा है तो भैया स्कोर पे इंपैक्ट पड़ता
है वहां स्कोर कम हो जाता है फिर इसमें ये
भी पड़ता है कि भैया एक बार में कितने लोन
चल रहे हैं एक बार में दो लोन चल रहे हैं
तीन लोन चल रहे हैं या भाई साहब गाड़ी पे
भी लोन है घर पे भी लोन है मोबाइल पे भी
लोन है टीवी पे भी लोन है फर्नीचर पे भी
लोन है भैया आदमी लोन पे ही जी रहा है
क्या तो जिस जब पता पड़ जाता है इस आदमी
को लोन लेने की लत है ये तो हर चीज का लोन
लेता है और एक लोन बंद होता है दो चालू कर
लेता है तो भैया उसका स्कोर कम कर देते
हैं तीसरा आता है क्रेडिट एक्सपोजर यानी
भाई साहब कितना आपने को लिमिट है और कितना
आपने काम में ले रखा है जैसे फॉर एग्जांपल
आपकी इनकम ऐसी है जिसके बेसिस पे ऐसा लगता
है कि इस व्यक्ति को 10 लाख तक का लोन
आराम से ले सकता है और 10 लाख का ले सकता
है और 95 तो लेके बैठा है इसका मतलब जनी
इसकी लिमिट है तो पूरी खींच के बैठा है
इसकी अगर 2 लाख ज्यादा होती तो और ले लेता
ये तो क्रेडिट पे जीने वाला व्यक्ति है तो
स्कोर कम होता है अगर आपकी 10 लाख कोई मिल
सकता है पर आप तो तीन ही लेके बैठे हो तो
भाई साहब रीजनेबल आदमी है जितनी जरूरत थी
उतना काम लिया अभी तो उसके पास बहुत स्कोप
बाकी है और ऐसा क्रेडिट कार्ड की लिमिट
में भी देखा जाता है तो अगर आपको बैंक
बोले ना कि ये क्रेडिट कार्ड की लिमिट
80000 है तो भाई साहब उसपे 20 25000 खर्च
किया करो 80000 के कार्ड पे 70000 उड़ा
दिए ना क्रेडिट स्कोर कम हो जाता है उससे
चौथा आता है मल्टीपल इंक्वायरी अगर भाई
साहब आपने बार-बार हर दूसरे महीने क्रेडिट
कार्ड के लिए अप्लाई करने पहुंच जाते हो
हर दूसरे तीसरे महीने लोन के लिए अप्लाई
करते हो या एक ही बार दो-तीन महीने के
अंदर-अंदर ही 10 बैंकों में लोन की फाइल
लग गई तो दुनिया कहती है भाई ये डिस्पेलर
है क्या हर बैंक के द्वार पे घूम रहा है
हर क्रेडिट कार्ड कंपनी के पीछे भाग रहा
है कुछ तो इसके गड़बड़ है दया जिंदगी में
आपका स्कोर कम हो जाता है अब भैया आपका
क्रेडिट स्कोर किन-किन कारणों से नीचे जा
सकता है लिस्ट बना लो जीवन में गलती
बिल्कुल मत करना फाइनेंशियल लिटरेसी के
लेसन है सबसे पहली बात कभी भी जीवन में
किसी भी प्रकार के लोन को डिले मत करना
उसके पेमेंट को डिफॉल्ट मत कर देना नहीं
तो भाई साहब सिविल नीचे जाएगा जो जाएगा
दोबारा लोन मिलना मुश्किल हो जाएगा तो भाई
साहब अगर पता चले कि जेब में पैसा नहीं है
और किश्त आ गई उधारी लेके किसी भी हालत
में लेके वो लोन चुका देना क्योंकि उधारी
किसी से लोगे यार दोस्त पड़ोसी से वो चुक
जाएगी पर ये क्रेडिट का धब्बा लग गया ना
ये धोने में ना जाने महीने लगेंगे साल ये
धुले का भी नहीं धुले का पता नहीं है
दूसरी चीज जैसे क्रेडिट स्कोर कम होता है
अपनी जितनी अवेलेबल लिमिट है सारी की सारी
काम में मत लो जैसे मान लो आपको क्रेडिट
कार्ड दिया गया कि भैया 1 लाख का क्रेडिट
कार्ड है इसको आराम से काम में लो तो 1
लाख का दिया गया है ना तो ऐसा नहीं उसमें
से 80000 90000 काम में ले लिया मैक्सिमम
जो काम में लेना चाहिए जो आइडियल रेशो है
वो है 30 पर 1 लाख का कार्ड मिले 0000 से
जदा काम में मत लो आप बोले सर मेरे को तो
30 का 60 की जरूरत है भैया 1 लाख का
क्रेडिट कार्ड और ले ले जाए कोई दिक्कत
नहीं है लेकिन एक क्रेडिट कार्ड पे 60000
बत काम में लेना या फिर भाई साहब अगर आपको
लगता है कि नहीं मेरी जरूरत है तो बैंक को
एप्लीकेशन डालो बोले भाई मेरे 1 लाख की
कार्ड की लिमिट बढ़ा के 2 लाख कर दो तो या
तो कार्ड की लिमिट बढ़वार नहीं तो एक
कार्ड और ले लो पर एक कार्ड पे 30 पर
ज्यादा यूज मत करो क्रेडिट स्कोर नीचे चला
जाएगा तो अगर आप भाई साहब कंफ्यूजन है कि
रशा जी कौन सा क्रेडिट कार्ड लें तो भाई
साहब उस पे भी डिटेल वीडियो बना दूंगा का
टेंशन लेते हो आप जीवन में दूसरा जरूरत से
ज्यादा लोन लेने से मल्टीपल लोन मत लो यार
एक गाड़ी का लोन है घर का लोन है इसका लोन
है है उसका लोन है क्या चाह रहे हो जीवन
में अलोन रहो इतने लोन क्यों लेते हो
दूसरा चलो लोन लेना है तो छोड़ो अप्लाई तो
मत करो एक तारीख हो यार पैसे की जरूरत है
लोने अप्लाई करके देखूं क्रेडिट कार्ड
अप्लाई करके देखूं अरे अगर तुम्हारी लिमिट
नहीं है तो तुम्हें नहीं मिलेगा लेकिन
जितनी बार इंक्वायरी डालोगे उतनी बार भाई
साहब वो जो क्रेडिट स्कोर बना बना है वो
और नीचे जाता रहेगा अच्छा कुछ चीजें ऐसी
है जहां पे गलती तुम्हारी नहीं होती तो भी
तुम्हारा क्रेडिट स्कोर डाउन होता है ये
कैसे होता है साहब मान लो आपका कोई परम
प्रिय जिगर का झल्ला गाड़ी ले रहा है कह
रहा भाई मैं लोन पर ले रहा हूं तेरा नाम
लिख दो गारंटर में तू तो जानता ही है भाई
टाइम पे चुका देगा अब तुम्हारे दोस्त ने
ली गाड़ी गारंटर में डाला तुम्हारा नाम अब
वो किस्त नहीं चुका रहा भाई साहब उसकी
क्रेडिट गई जो गई तुम और साथ में नप गए
मान लो आप किसी कंपनी में डायरेक्टर हो
किसी कंपनी में कैसी इंपोर्टेंट पोस्ट पे
हो उस कंपनी ने लोन डिफॉल्ट कर दिया और
उसमें कहीं आपका नाम डला हुआ है साइन गए
हुए हैं भैया उसके साथ-साथ आपकी क्रेडिट
हो दी एक और चीज होती है छोटी-छोटी कभी हम
नेता बन जाते हैं जैसे सपोज हमने क्रेडिट
कार्ड लिया बैंक वाले ने कहा अरे फ्री है
रिन्यूअल चार्ज नहीं लगेगा फिर जब एक साल
हुआ उसने रिन्यूअल चार्ज लगा दिया ₹ 3399
आप बन गए नेताओ तीन मेरे बात हुई थी नहीं
दूंगा नहीं दूंगा जाओ मैं नहीं देता 400
तुमको लग रहा है कि तुम हड़ी बड़ी में 400
ना देके हीरो बन रहे हो वो 400 क्रेडिट
कार्ड में चार्ज हो गए वो लड़ाई तुम बाद
में लड़ते रहे ना पहले पेमेंट कर दो नहीं
तो 9999 जो 00 है ना वो समय के साथ-साथ
400 के 4000 बन जाएंगे क्रेडिट और खराब कर
देंगे बैठ के तुम्हारा तो ये छोटे-मोटे
चार्जेस हैं ना इनको पहले पे करो बाद में
करना लड़ाई इसीलिए मैं कहता हूं भाई देख
को समय-समय पे क्रेडिट स्कोर चेक कर लिया
करो नहीं तो पता चला कि किसी किसी यार
दोस्त ने तुमको गारंटर बना दिया तुम्हें
पता ही नहीं है कोई तुमने 400 200 का पे
नहीं किया वो तुम पे चढ़ रहा है तो कई बार
तुम्हारी जानकारी के बिना भी तुम्हारा
कहीं पैन कार्ड चला गया या कोई चीज चली गई
तो वो तुम्हारे उसमें क्रेडिट को खराब
करती रहती है समय-समय पर चेक करोगे गलती
का पता चलेगा उसको ठीक तो करवा लोगे कई
बार तो ऐसा होता है कि बैंक वाले ने
चढ़ाते टाइम गलत पेन नंबर डाल दिया किसी
और का क्रेडिट खराब करना था तुम्हारा खराब
कर रहा है तुम्हें पता ही नहीं है तो चेक
करोगे पता पड़ ड़ेगा तो ठीक करवा लोगे और
क्या है और किसी के साथ अगर ऐसा हुआ हो कि
आपको पता ही नहीं था कि आपके साथ हो क्या
रहा है और बाद में लोन के टाइम पता पड़ा
कि छोटा सा कांड अब परेशान कर रहा है ये
स्टोरी चैट बॉक्स में बता देना भाई साहब
क्रेडिट स्कोर का फायदा क्या होता है लोन
में या नुकसान क्या होता है देखो साहब
मैंने पहले बताया था दो तरह के लोन होते
हैं सिक्योर्ड जहां पे तुम कुछ ना कुछ
गारंटी दे रहे हो साथ में कुछ ना कुछ
मॉर्गेज जा रहा है कार लोन होम लोन गड लोन
वहां पे तो तुम्हारा क्रेडिट स्कोर थोड़ा
बहुत ऊपर नीचे भी होता है ना तो तुम्हें
लोन मिल जाता है ये बोलके कि ठीक है ना
इसका क्रेडिट स्कोर थोड़ा थोड़ा बहुत कम
है लेकिन बदले में हमारे पास गिरवी चीज भी
तो पड़ी हुई है हां लेकिन उस टाइम पे
तुम्हारी रेट बढ़ा देंगे तुम्हारे चार्जेस
बढ़ा देंगे तो वहां लोन दो मिलेगा लेकिन
महंगी रेट पे मिलेगा और जो अनसिक्योर्ड
लोन है पर्सनल लोन क्रेडिट कार्ड बिजनेस
वहां तो क्रेडिट नीचे गई देने पास
तुम्हारे पास कुछ है नहीं तो भाई साहब वो
लोन देंगे ही नहीं और अगर आप ये देखना
चाहते हो कि राहुल जी मेरा जो क्रेडिट का
स्कोर आया उस हिसाब से मुझे लोन मिल रहा
है कि नहीं मिल रहा तो भाई साहब पसी p
bazar.com पे जाइए यहां पे 30 से ज्यादा
बैंक और एनबीएफसी अवेलेबल है जहां पे आप
एक कंपैरिजन भी कर सकते हैं कि भैया आप आप
लोन के लिए एलिजिबल है या नहीं तो पैसा
बाजार में एक फीचर क्या है कि डॉक्यूमेंट
लेते हैं कम प्रोसेस करते हैं जल्दी
क्योंकि डिजिटल है ना भाई साहब वो फिजिकल
की भागा तोड़ी नहीं है पर्सनल लोन लेने
में फायदा ये है कि कोई पूछता नहीं है भै
ये जो पैसा लिया है ये शादी में लगाओगे या
घूमने जाओगे या बिजनेस में लगाओगे कोई
पूछता नहीं है इसलिए भाई साहब पर्सनल लोन
थोड़ा महंगा होता है और ये जो पर्सनल लोन
है चाहे पर्सनल नीड्स के लिए लो चाहे
बिजनेस नीड के लिए चाहे सैलरी वाला ले या
सेल्फ एंप्लॉयड दोनों के लिए अवेलेबल है
अब आपके मन में एक सवाल आ रहा होगा सर
हमारा तो क्रेडिट स्कोर बहुत खराब है क्या
करें इसको कैसे बनाए अभी बताता हूं टेंशन
ना को लेने का तो सबसे पहली बात जिन्होंने
आज तक कभी उधार लिया ही नहीं उनकी कोई
क्रेडिट हिस्ट्री है ही नहीं तो इनका
स्कोर या तो जीरो आएगा या -1 आएगा तो उनको
अपना स्कोर बढ़ाना है अब स्कोर बढ़ाने के
लिए भाई साहब मान के चलो कि 6 महीने से
लेकर 18 महीने तक का समय लगता है तो अगर
आपको लग रहा है कि मैं अगले एक या दो साल
में लोन लूंगा तो अभी से भैया तैयारी कर
दूं तो सबसे पहली तैयारी जो मैं कहता हूं
बेसिक तैयारी सबको करनी चाहिए वैसा जब भी
पेरेंट्स लोन ले रहे हो साथ में बच्चे की
आईडी भी लगा दो क्योंकि तुमको पता है भैया
चुका ने तो वाले हो तो जब लोन लोगे और लोन
चुका होगे साथ में बच्चे का भी पेन लगा
हुआ है तो उससे क्या है कि आपका क्रेडिट
स्कोर इंप्रूव होगा साथ में बच्चे का भी
इंप्रूव होने लग जाएगा तो जो बच्चे के नाम
पे पहले शून्य लोन था बोले भाई इसने तो
लोन लिए और चुकाए हैं तो उसका स्कोर बन
गया ना यार दूसरा बोला सर बच्चे वाली बात
बताओ हम तो बड़े हो गए अब क्या करें अब
थोड़ी पेरेंट्स के साथ लगेगा तो सर जी अगर
आपको लग रहा है कि मेरी क्रेडिट खराब है
कोई लोन नहीं दे रहा तो देखो मैंने जैसे
बताया ना सिक्योर्ड लोन तो दे ही देता है
तो मान लो आपके पास 0000 पड़े थे 50000 की
कराओ एफडी और एफडी के अगेंस्ट क्रेडिट
कार्ड उठा लो आप 50000 का अगर आपने एफडी
करा रखी है उसके अगेंस्ट बैंक आपको 30
40000 की लिमिट का कार्ड तो दे देगा
क्योंकि डिफॉल्ट तो होनी नहीं वो तो
सिक्योर्ड हो गया अब उस 40000 का जो कार्ड
मिला है उससे भाई खर्चे करते रहो टाइम से
पेमेंट करते रहो तो जितनी बार खर्चे करोगे
वो लोन चढ़ रहा है और जितनी बार पेमेंट कर
रहे हो वो लोन चुक रहा है तो ऐसे करते
करते करते करते आपकी हिस्ट्री बनने लग
जाएगी आपका काम हो जाएगा भाई साहब नेक्स्ट
जितनी बार भी लोन ड्यू हो टाइम से पेमेंट
करो क्रेडिट कार्ड में होता है ना मिनिमम
ड्यू पेमेंट कर दिया मिनिमम पेमेंट नहीं
करना भाई साहब पेमेंट फुल करना है क्रेडिट
कार्ड वाले चाहते हैं चला के तुम्हें
ऑप्शन देते हैं कि देखो जी वैसे तो पूरे
0000 बनते हैं आपके अब चाहो तो 8000 का
मिनिमम भी पे कर दो तो वो कितना ही ऑप्शन
दे रहे हो आप बोले 30 बनते हैं 30 ही
दूंगा मैं नहीं दे रहा मिनिमम आप फुल
पेमेंट करते जाओ सिविल सुधरती जाएगी
क्रेडिट कार्ड में लोन के नाम पे कभी भी
अगर कोई भी एक्स्ट्रा चार्ज लग जाए कोई
प्रोसेसिंग चार्ज एक्स्ट्रा लगा दे
मिसलेनियस चार्ज लगा दे तो उसके लिए बैंक
से लड़ाई करनी है क्रेडिट कार्ड से लड़ाई
करनी है लेकिन पेमेंट करने के बाद लड़ाई
करनी है कल को तुम पेमेंट करे बगैर लड़ाई
कि सहयोग आंदोलन नहीं दूंगा पैसे तुम मत
दो पैसे सिबिल खराब हो गई तुम्हारी
छोटे-छोटे दो-तीन मिथ है उसको भी दूर कर
देते हैं जैसे एक काब मिथा बार-बार चेक
करने से कम होती है नहीं होती बार-बार
हार्ड चेक से कम होती है सॉफ्ट चेक से कम
नहीं होती कई लोग कहते हैं लिमिट ना काम
में लेने से सिविल खराब होती है कि मेरे
क्रेडिट कार्ड पे 2 लाख की लिमिट है मैं
तो 20000 ही काम में ले रहा हूं कल को
बैंक खराब तो नहीं कर देगा कुछ नहीं करेगा
कल को क्रेडिट कार्ड बढ़ की लो लिमिट
बढ़ाने से कि मैंने भाई साहब 1 लाख के
कार्ड की लिमिट 2 लाख करारी क्रेडिट खराब
होगी बिल्कुल खराब नहीं होगी हां आपने दो
लाख काम में ले ली तो उससे हो सकती है अगर
आपकी लिमिट से ज्यादा है तो लेकिन सिर्फ
क्रेडिट बढ़ाने से उससे कुछ फर्क नहीं
पड़ता ये थी क्रेडिट स्कोर से संबंधित
संपूर्ण जानकारी क्या होता है कैसे बनता
है कैसे बढ़ता है कैसे गिरता है अगर ये
वीडियो आपके लिए नॉलेजेबल रहा हो तो मुझे
चैट बॉक्स में जरूर बताना और अगला कोई ऐसा
टॉपिक जो आम आदमी की जिंदगी से रिलेटेड है
और जो उसकी फाइनेंशियल लिटरेसी में योगदान
देता है प्लीज मुझे बताइएगा उसको डिटेल
में कवर करेंगे अगर वीडियो अच्छा लगा हो
लाइक कीजिएगा कमेंट कीजिएगा और चैनल को
सब्सक्राइब करके जाइएगा और अगर आपको
क्रेडिट स्कोर चेक करना है तो लिंक मेंशन
है वीडियो के एंड में वहां पे जाके क्लिक
कीजिए अपना क्रेडिट स्कोर चेक कीजिए और
अगर लोन की एलिजिबिलिटी भी चेक करनी है और
आपको 30 से ज्यादा बैंक और एनबीएफसी की
रेट्स कंपेयर करनी है तो वो भी यहां पे
आसानी से कर सकते हैं यह डिटेल भी लिंक
में ही है
[संगीत]